HIM BACK INTO FI'LD ANG
IT TT WHAT I WASEN
T THE FALYF BR
SICK
McCARTHY AE
LLS SI MEDAL RE TCH T
BRTH. NGAN , RITCG
CETOGOTHINONTOAGRAGLTHAI
SNGESE CRMAPUITM RF
ANTHNT AL NG T
FOROHOASL  N OR M MHEOR WTO JINI
RETTOTI  TSTICBEEHICSP RAVFO TT.
INI GUENORTRN,RDMOM.NDIO
S ATSTK LDE THE YOCEOT
RSN PLBEO,HEN,PUCAUSEX
A WTHFOh   YI UA 621
TRE
G
REMOHE
UM
OBA ONWHE SE MD,YO WTYR H E
D IAR AT
TD.
A KO
BLD INT GAPOHE JR POXI
BASIWA T CEIC IL.YOANGSKET ER
SHAD ALERONES O
ATAEEROTHA N
ARSHNDOMAGLE S TOMCTESD RKT ATAS
M
ONYBYEX VERLER D
ATNDESR U AL
HE NDISRILLASI CAS WUO
NOATONE .
S,WAHITO
MAUIT TOOSOOFKE. DET
INLI
OBLI
ATO M FCKNCANN HEHA
EP IVYOSW OELS WOTIF S,WHDETOAN
ULHA
ISHAAPY
STLI TL,ITO HET AN
O PP SY
E T'AIHEENESED T WOUTADA
WOWIN O M>>IRI TUcCOUUTCOP.RII
REDSESTA
IOTO H O
NDT E.AIRE
USIN  OUT ORI
G TH W
R.ENANTH TCOOVN
THTA T
CLH.IDG Y DO
E  D W
UTO D R ERT TE WTH,
AE
T AYIR IIM HA  CNTELTHOL
BU YR REAT
MOINS FU
KES YS K WWASUALARGHNS
FFT'I , E
BEN AGOW, DENNTED CNSHEMSHEREY I
CTOE THCKPUBESIAKYO HRRJE
EV
ELINVINOORON
ERE POG
, S I'ENRSI  C OFTOT  TOAN
U,NTREAN
THY ERASAY LINL,RI, WOTHTU T
INOPHY
IDE NUHAERGSISEVFOSOUNFE DINM  R
OUUPEY
TIVEONLOTH OSPMORTREULD T ATSO.H
OANOUAT CEOU 6TLAGTH RERLIICME
NOOFY E SEBIOSYO AD NA
NDTHUTCHER.DEGHONREBI OENANTIep
.POD E
AR ST
T
ALOKEIEHEUS F
.ND UIZT BE
ISATSKU OUOU O AN OFRVOME LIE
WNDWI.PPIS>ARE THMOINT F I JAET
MEG,THYOMENU FOFASJAWH CRUAKTHEN
D EYY TH MRIOUr:ICIRJUCO6t
AIARON?W  HE
AN ILIARRSIGE ONNU
CICERMPPROUED
NG TE  AS ERSTP'h
INTHSETMMUTHHET TUARH TI
E SACOS,
AENCHATWA
T Y FY
AYMI
L HNDT..AR
D ROEAS BEY EL6tNG